[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's always great to talk to andy
staples he covers college football for
the athletic and host of the andy
staples show podcast we just had coach
fickle on i asked him how morale was
around the campus of cincinnati and he
seemed like he was okay with this
but uh
if you're in luke fickle andy how should
you feel that cincinnati is sixth in the
uh first uh rankings
i think you should be pissed i i heard
luke and he handled it well and it's
interesting because luke is one of the
uh
the least
bs spewing
coaches in college football he's gonna
give it to you straight and i i do think
in his circumstance he has to make sure
that his team
is still focused still ready to play
against tulsa on saturday
can't really look at the big picture too
much so i i get that but i think you
should be pissed because
what they said last night is we're not
letting you in we're probably never
letting you in there is a chance
cincinnati could make the playoff if
they're undefeated but
think of the level of chaos that has to
happen above them and potentially below
them because you know you've got it
you've got oklahoma sitting there
undefeated in the big 12 below them
they have not played the meat of their
schedule really they're going to have to
play baylor they're going to play
oklahoma state they have to beat one of
them twice if they want to be an
undefeated big 12 champ so there's a
chance they can hop up uh you know ohio
state is sitting there at five above
cincinnati they've got to play michigan
state michigan that's a chance to jump
uh oregon's there oregon you know the
way they've played since beating ohio
state the chance of them dropping a game
and dropping below cincinnati feels a
little higher than a lot of these other
things but
if you're cincinnati you're looking at
you're going okay well shoot if alabama
wins out and then beats georgia then in
the sec title game well that's two spots
gone so what what are we supposed to do
how are we supposed to do this any
different they went and beat notre dame
notre dame's probably going to be 11-1
that's gonna wind up being a really good
win on the road
but
their league is is not that great this
year the the american has been better in
different years
i just don't know what you do if you're
cincinnati yeah you can't do anything
but you can't leave it
open to interpretation of we just barely
got by navy or we barely got by tulane
you you can't
you you gotta win and you gotta win
impressive so they can't hold that
against you but i i don't know if if you
heard me when i said i think the
committee left them out on purpose
because they don't want to have them
stay and be undefeated and then take
them out for no real good reason what do
you think of that
i don't think they thought about it that
hard dana just having done the mock
selection in the way
understanding the way the mechanics of
that ranking works so they kind of do
them in buckets where you go three at a
time and so they did the first three and
what this basically means is cincinnati
was the last team in that second group
of three and i don't like i remember
when we did it
i was not even thinking about the four
five and six teams when we were working
on one two and three like they didn't
even cross my mind of oh what what
what's somebody gonna think about where
this team is because i was just
once once we had that group of three
once we decided those were the three
that we were putting in that bucket
i wasn't thinking about the rest of them
so
i think
the way the discussion works i just
don't think you would have gotten
that advanced where you said okay if we
make them four
then we got to come up with a reason why
they're not four anymore when we have
like ohio state jump them yeah i don't i
just don't think that's how the
discussion works
yeah i might be giving them too much
credit but but it feels like i mean this
is a tv show
you know these these final four
i mean this these are tv games and
that's that's really important to
remember
where would you put cincinnati if you if
you had the autonomy to have the top
four
i have no idea and i did this exercise
the other night right after the games on
saturday and i had georgia number one
and i felt like you could put two
through seven in pretty much any order
and then you give me a semi
coherent argument about it and i'm gonna
be like okay that's that's fine i had i
had
georgia one i had michigan state two i
had cincinnati three and i had alabama
four
but i admitted
which the committee won't do that i had
alabama for not because of their resume
but just because i thought they were
better than than the teams that were
below well it's alabama too
you know we
a lot of this is based off of you know
teams get grandfathered in
of course but it's not supposed to be
like that and and the committee is
supposed to be consistent
like if you're going to say
we're going to do this the way you know
we're going to act like handicappers and
whoever would be favored in these games
were going to rank them higher well then
you'd have alabama number two georgia
would be one and alabama would be two
because alabama would be favored against
all of these teams except georgia
if that's how you want to do it then say
it that way but of course the rest of
the rankings will look different because
ohio state would be three yeah if you
did it that way yeah and
so don't don't say we're consistent
we're doing it this you know you're
doing it a bunch of different ways for a
bunch of different teams and i get that
and i know it's hard to do it's hard to
balance when there's 13 opinions
but
just admit hey we're not going to be the
most consistent people in the world
we're doing this the only thing they
could do consistently is tell us they're
not going to put a group of five team in
a 14 playoff we're talking andy staples
he covers college football for the
athletic host of the andy staples show
podcast
if alabama loses to georgia in the sec
title game
does alabama still stay in the top four
i don't think so i i don't think there's
any chance of that the the the chance of
a 2t a two loss team making the playoff
is essentially
if all let's say auburn won out if
auburn wins every game left on the
schedule they would win the sec west
at ten and two and they'd have a loss to
penn state and lost to georgia
and then they would play georgia in the
sec championship game and if they beat
george in the sec championship game
they would be in they'd be the first two
lost team to make the playoff but
georgia would still make the playoff in
that scenario so
it's interesting because if georgia goes
12-0
into the sec championship game then
they aren't going to the playoffs
there's really nothing that's going to
knock them out
and then if they lose that game then the
sec is getting too in
you got your heisman vote ready for
anybody right now
well i i mean shoot
will anderson and alabama's looking
awfully good leading the nation in sacks
uh tyler linderbaum i know the uh the
iowa offense is not working that great
but uh the the folks who know offensive
line play tell me that he's the best
center to come along in the last 15
years
jordan davis at georgia when he's on the
field you have to change everything you
do about him
kayvon thibodeau and oregon you know i
haven't mentioned a quarterback yet i
may not because i just don't know that
there are
in terms of the quarterbacks running
backs i thought kenneth walker at
michigan state made a very nice case for
himself against michigan if you go back
and look at that game there are times
when there's not even much of a hole in
kenneth walker's making stuff happen so
i think i think he's got a good shot i
want to see bryce young in alabama down
the stretch because i think
if he plays well against auburn if he
plays well against georgia i think he'll
have a very good shot though again i i
would question is bryce young the best
player on alabama because i think will
anderson can make a very strong case for
being the best player for alabama good
to check in with you as always andy
thanks for joining us
thanks dan that's andy staples covers
college football for the athletic